the devil on your shoulder your guardian
angel these are expressions that we've
all heard countless times of course
they're not supposed to be taken
literally none of us have a Heavenly
Spirit looking over us and protecting us
from harm in the same way that nobody
really has a little red-skinned imp
Whispering encouragement to commit
atrocious deeds in someone's ear their
metaphors Guardian Angel refers to any
instance of seemingly divine
intervention but is more often a
coincidence that ends up benefiting a
person when they need it most and the
devil on your shoulder that's Temptation
the little voice in the back of your
head that sometimes eggs you on to do
something you know you shouldn't but
what if there was a being that was both
a demonic malicious creature that also
acted as a guardian for someone unable
to protect themselves is it even
possible for a being to be both angel
and devil and who out there could ever
qualify for such holy and hellish
ombre Rouge was once a fairly normal
place to live a small Louisiana Town in
one of the smallest of these 50 United
States its name was derived from the
French language translating to Red
Shadow an ominous name for a Township
that was otherwise so uninteresting and
forgettable in fact if things had never
panned out the way they had
ombre Rouge would have stayed that way
just a place where nothing interesting
ever happened all of that changed of
course when the disappearances started
for anyone who might be too young to
remember them the mid-2000s were a
turbulent time the Iraq war was in full
swing and a nationwide financial crisis
was rapidly approaching but in the midst
of all this Global chaos and instability
the residents of ombre Rouge were soon
to be caught in the thralls of their
very own shared torment at first like
with most bad things it started small
one person went missing an unfortunate
occurrence but not exactly unheard of
sadly these things happen especially
when you live so close to the swamplands
of Louisiana people wander out into the
marsh under the Searing Heat Of The Sun
only to suffer heat stroke collapse and
end up buried in the dark dank mud never
to be seen again few of those living in
the town took much notice of the first
disappearance apart from the missing
person's relatives many just Shrugged
off the news as sad as it was most of
the townsfolk were just grateful it
hadn't happened to any of their own
family or friends maybe it was that
ignorance that lack of vigilance or
reaction that meant a second resident
would also be reported missing not long
after the first but this time was
different unlike the previous
disappearance this one had an eyewitness
Clement Donovan known to locals as Clem
had spotted a passerby while taking out
bags of garbage this unassuming
pedestrian was the second disappearance
victim thinking little of the man who
just seemed to be walking home Clem went
back inside a split second later he
heard a scream from outside and rushed
back to his dimly lit porch it was there
that Clem claimed he saw something
retreating towards the nearby Woods
however Clem's wild story of something
not quite human wasn't taken seriously
by local police he even managed to snap
a grainy photo on his clamshell cell
phone but back in 2005 phone cameras
were nowhere near as advanced as they
are today most ombre Rouge locals wrote
Clem off as a crazy old man at best but
worst it made him look like someone who
is trying to exploit or make light of
the disappearances something that
garnered him a lot of dirty looks from
his neighbors that was until a number of
other residents started reporting they
had also witnessed a humanoid creature
it's hard to save any of these
eyewitnesses were genuine and how many
were just people latching on to Clem's
story regardless the disappearances
hadn't stopped and it didn't take long
for an unknown organization to roll into
on play Rouge after hearing the rumors
of a creature sighting a few residents
even the local sheriff's department
thought these Shady Figures were a
division of forensic Specialists here to
Aid in the investigations into the
missing persons the more conspiratorial
folks living in the town had a different
explanation that the newcomers were a
deep state-controlled top-secret
government group there to assess the
possibility that there really was some
kind of monster on the loose not long
after this group had arrived in ombre
Rouge the number of residents going
missing seemed to dwindle on the 18th of
December 2005 they packed up and left
town giving no explanation to the local
police nobody knew if this secretive
Foundation had actually uncovered the
perpetrator responsible for all the
disappear appearances if there even was
any creature like the rumors said but
whatever had transpired in that
Louisiana swamp Town one thing was clear
the moment the foundation left nobody
else went missing from on play Rouge or
at least not for over a decade before
then however little else of note
happened in ombre Rouge after the
initial Spate of missing persons cases
this apart from a car accident that took
place just under a year after the
various disappearances ended a heavily
injured Man by the name of Simon Hayes
was taken to a local hospital suffering
from a severe concussion Simon had been
involved in a collision with a car on
the 11th of November 2006. the doctors
that examined him determined that Simon
had been left with short-term retrograde
amnesia a condition that affected all
his memories from prior to the accident
it was due to this that he was unable to
recall events that occurred in the years
before he'd sustained his injuries now
what is it
random if unfortunate car accident
victims so significant well Simon Hayes
actually became the first person in
ombre Rouge to be declared missing in
almost a decade in 2016 10 years after
his accident at 11 after the original
slew of disappearances Simon vanished
when returning to his hometown in
Louisiana to visit his family naturally
Simon Hayes wouldn't be the last
familiar face to return to the town a
repetition of such similar and strange
occurrences as before also brought the
mysterious Foundation rolling back in
little did the townsfolk know in the
year that had followed the group's
original Exodus from Emperor Rouge they
had lost something on the exact same day
Simon suffered his accident whatever it
was the foundation had left town with
had managed to escape perhaps this was a
purely coincidental occurrence but what
if it wasn't after all road traffic
collisions take place all the time all
over the world but an accident happened
in a town with a history of people going
missing on the exact same day that this
thing escaped captivity maybe there was
a link between the two events at the
very least the foundation seemed to
think so some of the more astute people
living in the swamp side Town noticed
black Armored Transport vehicles moving
into their neighborhoods men in body
armor locking down the whole of ombre
Rouge these didn't seem like local
police they weren't even the National
Guard although they were certainly
heavily armed enough to cause concern
this unit of specially trained
operatives quickly took control of the
entire Township their authority never
questioned by the sheriff's department
the place was small enough isolated by
surrounding swamps and Marshland that
was easy for mobile task force Epsilon 6
to get away with an operation like this
before the people of ombre Rouge had
time to argue the task force had already
begun their investigation the newest
series of disappearances had started in
26 16 with Simon Hayes mysteriously
Vanishing and had continued two years
later in 2018 just like the first fate
back in 2005 there were sporadic and
unconfirmed eyewitness accounts of a
creature shaped like a human but
considerably taller almost two meters in
height most Witnesses reported only ever
seeing this local Boogeyman at night
time making it much harder to see in
detail although a few seemed to State
its skin was deep red unlike any natural
human skin tone while before residents
of the Louisiana swamp Town had brushed
off stories like this as nothing more
than rumors and urban legends the
foundation seemed pretty receptive to
the idea of some kind of monster on the
loose in the Marshland and after all
they had good reason to believe such an
outlandish story because it was the same
creature that had already escaped from
them in 2006 continuing their
investigation into the link between
Simon Hayes and this creature mobile
task Force Epsilon 6 also known by the
code name the village idiots arrived at
Hayes's place of residence kicking the
door down breaching the house they began
a room by room sweep looking for any
clues that would explain why the monster
they'd captured escaped on the same day
as Simon's accident one of the MTF
operatives uncovered something an
envelope stashed in the home Simon had
grown up in he opened it cautiously a
collection of papers that were contained
inside Kane's spilling out there were a
series of simple drawings on paper that
seemed to be more than a few years old
the crudeness of the hand scrawled
pictures and age of the paper seemed to
imply that they had been created by a
child a number of the drawings depicted
the same thing a red-skinned creature
just like the one the townsfolk had
reported seeing with them was a note
written by Simon's mother which read
found these old drawings of yours
thought you might like to see them again
welcome home there was a link an unclear
maybe tangential connection but one that
was growing the more information the
foundation uncovered whatever this being
was a very young Simon Hayes had seen it
while growing up in ombre Rouge due to
the short-term retrograde amnesia that
he'd sustained after his accident he
wouldn't have remembered it but perhaps
this thing remembered him did that mean
the pair of them might be linked somehow
not just by coincidence but some kind of
connection that allowed the creature to
escape its captivity on the exact day
Simon had his car accident a connection
that a drawn Haze back home to ombre
Rouge or drawn the Beast to Simon to
kidnap him moving fast MTF Epsilon 6
began to rapidly sweep the remainder of
the Town searching for any further signs
that would lead them to the whereabouts
of either Simon Hayes or this elusive
crimson-skinned Boogeyman they
interviewed residents and chased cold
leads before eventually backing their
target into a corner the foundation's
MTF operatives mapped the low education
of every eyewitness report of the
creature using that information to track
it back to a possible point of origin it
was a barn left abandoned practically
falling apart as it stood in a state of
disrepair just outside the small
Louisiana Town under the cover of
Darkness the task force approached the
wooden structure weapons locked and
loaded keeping them trained on the barn
cautiously moving closer remaining on
high alert the squad activated their
night vision there was a low almost
undetectable sound of movement coming
from within the barn slowly the mtf's
leader pushed open the wooden door and
peeked inside it was there he saw what
they had been looking for the thing that
had escaped the foundation over 10 years
before
scp-3631 a man and his monster the Beast
was just over six feet tall its skin a
bloody shade of crimson just as some of
the eyewitnesses had described it
sported a pair of arms and bipedal legs
giving it a humanoid shape however that
was exactly where its likeness to human
beings ended the creature later
designated as
scp-3631-1 lacked ears eyes or a nose
only a wide-gaping Maw of sharp teeth
its face was covered in holes that
twitched and puckered like smaller
miniature mouths in actuality it used
these orifices for various senses it
smelled saw and detected sounds through
the holes in its otherwise mostly
featureless face as the members of MTF
Epsilon 6 enter the barn stealthily
making sure not to alert
scp-3631-1 they cited something else
someone else was in the barn with it a
man not a dead victim or another monster
like
scp-3631-1 but an actual living
breathing human man MTF Epsilon 6's
Commander gave his Squad the signal to
engage hearing the sounds of weapons
cocking around it the creature turned
into
crawling on all fours like an
animalistic Predator at first it reared
back it wasn't until one member of the
task force approached that
scp-3631-1 retaliated attacking the
foundation operatives in a frenzy
following a prolonged and bloody
exchange MTF Epsilon 6 managed to subdue
the creature and were able to once again
return it to Foundation captivity but
this time unlike back in 2005 they had
scp-3631-2 as well as the red monster
was prepped for transport a survivor of
the task force noticed something an ID
perhaps a driver's license on the iman's
person the Epsilon 6 operative picked
the card up wiping away smears of blood
with a glove finger enough to reveal a
single familiar name printed on it Simon
Hayes before long just like last time
the foundation rolled back out of ombre
Rouge leaving the Louisiana townsfolk
none the wiser about what had happened
there little did they know the Red
Shadow hanging over their home had been
lifted but it had come at the cost of a
number of disappearances that would
remain unsolved people who would never
be found families forced to go on
without Ever Getting answers when he was
returned to the foundation's labs
scp-3631-2 was sent for extensive
examination given the severity of the
invasive organ transplant seat undergone
it was impossible to tell if he was in
fact Simon the creature had been
regularly replacing the man's internal
organs on a monthly basis whenever they
showed signs of Decay or failing somehow
despite the high risk of blood loss and
infection posed by this crude form of
surgery the subject had remained alive
but he was unable to speak conscious but
showing very limited responses to
stimuli nobody knows why the carnivorous
nocturnal monster
scp-3631-1 took this man captive in the
same vein it is unclear why the creature
felt such a need to protect
going to such lengths as hunting for
replacement organs from unwilling donors
perhaps in a grisly Twisted way
scp-3631-1 was this man's guardian angel
or maybe more a devil on his shoulder I
wonder is it really possible for
something to be both now go and check
out scp-096 the Shy Guy and scp-049 the
plague doctor for more Tales of creepy
and cruel creatures that you really
don't want to have any close encounters
with